eher abweisen oder aufnehmen das ist die
ganz große frage auf die es bisher
zumindest keine wirklich klaren
antworten gibt das wollen wir jetzt hier
live diskutieren uns zugeschaltet ist
der grüne bundestagsabgeordnete marcel
emmerich und auch sachsens cdu
innenminister roland wöller jetzt bei
uns einen schönen guten tag schön dass
sie bei uns in geduld das würde herr
emmerich lassen sie uns zusammen in
diese gesichter schauen wie wir eben
gerade gesehen haben kinder die im wald
sind die frieren die jetzt zu einem jahr
spielball in diesem zynischen machtspiel
geworden sind was soll man jetzt machen
wohin mit diesen menschen henrich
ja man muss erstmal deutlich machen dass
hier auf dem rücken von schutzsuchenden
einfach machtspielchen von lukaschenka
ausgeübt werden das ist ein großes
problem und das führt zu dieser
dramatischen situation das heißt es war
auch erster an erster stelle mal noch
mal stärkere sanktionen gegen das
libysche regime
es braucht auch schärfere maßnahmen
gegen die fluglinien die die flüchtlinge
herholen unter falschen versprechungen
und ihnen hoffnung geben und zieht dann
in diese wirklich dramatische situation
meine früheren man sieht ist den
menschen ist selbst kalt ist es um den
gefrierpunkt was sind schon menschen
gestorben es gibt kein wasser kann gute
versorgung das ist das auch dass es
jetzt ankommt und in dem zusammenhang
als auch wichtig dass es endlich möglich
wird dass hilfsorganisationen dort
hinkommen ich habe heute auch schon mit
menschen vor ort gesprochen die sich
darüber beschweren dass sie da den
menschen nicht helfen können in dieser
misslichen lage und das ist etwas was
auf jeden fall mal die humanitäre
antwort der europäischen union sein muss
und dafür muss muss jetzt müssen jetzt
die entsprechenden vorkehrungen
getroffen werden sie haben oft ganz
vieles geantwortet er immer ich aber
noch nicht auf die frage von unserer von
meiner kollegin patricia die frage mit
der wir gerne einsteigen wollten war
diese was wir jetzt ganz konkret mit
diesen menschen machen wir diskutieren
danach noch tiefer politisch aber die
stehen ja jetzt da am zaun das heißt für
die selbst stellt sich ja genau diese
konkrete frage für ihr leben im grunde
also wohin mit denen nehmen wir die
menschen auf die am zaun stehen ja oder
nein
also ich ich muss noch mal betonen ich
habe da mit leuten vor ort heute morgen
erst gesprochen und die erste erste
wichtige frage ist was passierte mit den
menschen wie kann man ihnen jetzt in
dieser akuten notsituation helfen wie
kann man dafür sorgen dass sie genug
nahrungsmittel haben die kann man dafür
sorgen dass sie etwas zu trinken haben
warme decken das ist mal das erste was
jetzt die europäische union leisten kann
und leisten muss und dann geht es um die
fragen was man mit den menschen macht da
ist immer ganz klar dass es rechtzeitig
verfahren dafür gibt und diese müssen in
diesem moment auch angewandt werden die
europäische union hat ja auch schon ihre
unterstützung dafür angeboten und polen
wäre in meinen augen gut beraten diese
anzunehmen aber es ist wirklich mir
nochmal ganz wichtig weil das heute noch
einmal geschildert bekommen hat wie
dramatisch die lage ist dass man vor
allem
hilfsorganisationen den zugang gewährt
damit die den menschen in not helfen
können sc staatlich sagen sie hernach
ich aber rechtsstaatlich heißt ja nicht
da hinzugehen den zaun durchzuschneiden
de und sich mit gewalt auf die andere
seite zu drängen herr bilder wie sehen
sie das denn was muss mit den menschen
vor ort passieren
also wir haben es mit einer staatlich
organisierten schleusung zu tun wir
haben gesehen dass diese gewaltsam
versuchen die grenze zu sprechen europa
darf sich nicht erpressbar machen und
das erste was wir machen müssen wir
müssen den polen erst einmal danken dass
die wirksam die außengrenzen der
europäischen union schützen und damit
schützen sie auch deutschland damit
schützen sie europa und wir müssen die
polen dabei unterstützen sozusagen diese
grenzen auch weiter wirksam zu
verteidigen es kann nicht sein dass sich
europa erpressbar macht durch einen
staatlichen ober schleuser und insofern
wird dafür geachtet werden dass keine
gewaltsamen grenzt durchbrüche möglich
sind das teilen ganz viele mit ihnen
diese meinung herr will auch die meinung
von herrn emmerich teilen ganz viele
aber wir befinden uns doch hier in dem
wahn singen dilemma zwischen moral und
politik und genau diese situation spielt
sich eben an diesem zaun ab deswegen
auch noch mal an sie herr weller wir
haben diese bilder von dem kleinen 14
jährigen ahmad dort gesehen heute früh
der sagt germany germany good people
sind dass dort in deutschland der will
dorthin und jetzt sagen sie an dem zaun
stehend sagen die grenzsoldaten no kein
weg in die eu halten sie das durch herr
weller
die frage ist was passiert wenn wir das
nicht durchhalten dann kommen noch mehr
leute also täglich landen zwischen 800
und 1000 das dann übrigens nicht kleine
kinder und frauen
sondern 85 prozent handelt sich um junge
männer das ist klar dass nur die bilder
gezeigt werden von kleinen kindern das
kommt uns bekannt vor das ist ja nicht
falsch aber richtig ist es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen gut gemeint und gut
wenn wir jetzt die menschen durch
passieren lassen was übrigens auch nicht
rechtens ist es gibt kein recht
gewaltsam eine grenze durchbrechen dann
kommen noch mehr und dann hat der
diktator lukaschenko europa dort wo es
haben will nämlich das verpresste sind
und wenn wir presber sind dann werden
wir sozusagen auch in anderen
außengrenzen erpressbar werden einen
riesigen zustrom haben wir haben seit
august ja bereits zahlen von über 9000
und gestern waren es 173 das werden wir
das wird deutschland auch nicht lange
weiter durchhalten können sind die leute
wollen nicht nach polen sie wollen auch
nicht in litauen lettland bleiben
sondern sie wollen nach deutschland
und das können wir unmöglich leisten und
deshalb kommt es jetzt darauf an die
außengrenze wirksam zu schützen die
polen dabei zu unterstützen wirksame
sanktionen gegen die fluggesellschaften
die das geschäft betreiben aus istanbul
aus dubai beispielsweise aber auch aus
damaskus die verdienen nicht nur daran
sondern sie betreiben das geschäft der
schlepper und hier brauchen wir start
und landeverbot wir brauchen sanktionen
gegebenenfalls auch mit hilfe der
ukraine über flugverbote genau das muss
jetzt die europäische kommission leisten
der schlüssel liegt in brüssel und liegt
in moskau er liegt allerdings nicht in
dresden in schwerin oder potsdam der
sanktionen da ist man sich ja wirklich
schon überparteilich einig also lassen
sie uns doch mal konkret jetzt hier bei
dieser situation lassen sie uns in
diesem zaun bleiben was man jetzt tun
kann er immer ich haben gerade hierzu
gehört weil er sagte wenn wir jetzt
diese menschen rein wenn wir da helfen
wenn wir sie herausholen auch aus diesem
leid aus dieser situation frierend in
den bädern dagegen wie lukaschenko genau
das was er will dann ist europa ganz
europa die eu da wo der letzte diktator
europas und haben will was setzen sie
dem entgegen
naja man muss sich ja auch mal fragen
warum man immer wieder in diese lage
kommt dass irgendwelche autoritären
staaten irgendwie diktatoren die
europäische union so unter druck setzen
können das liegt daran dass die
europäische union seit jahren die
migrationsfrage nicht abschließend
geklärt hat dass es kein
funktionierendes system gibt und das ist
doch der punkt da liegt der hund
begraben
und das ist einfach eine situation wo
die europäischen staaten wo die
europäische union jetzt in zukunft
wieder mit mehr vehemenz daran arbeiten
müssen wir haben solche ähnlichen bilder
ja schon an der türkischen an der
türkisch-griechischen grenze gesehen wir
sehen solche bilder oder seen bilde
eigentlich selten davon aber es gibt die
gleiche situation auf dem mittelmeer und
das ist der punkt da hat die europäische
union einfach eine verantwortung hier
mit einer humanen
migrationspolitik wirklich zu zeigen
dass sie ein würdiger
friedensnobelpreisträger ist wenn sie
das hören herr weller als sächsischer
innenminister das wird der sound
demnächst auch der ampel regierung
vermutlich sein ist so die stirn zu
bieten einem diktator lukaschenko mit
diesem sound im ausland beispielsweise
im bundesinnenministerium im
bundesverteidigungsministerium
also es geht meiner ansicht nach nicht
darum irgendwelche friedensnobelpreise
zu gewinnen sondern es geht ja wohl um
humanität das hat deutschland gezeigt
dass hat europa gezeigt in hohem ausmaß
es geht aber auch in ordnung es geht um
rechtsstaatlichkeit wir können unmöglich
illegale migration zu lassen sekundär
mit migration innerhalb der europäischen
union und wir müssen auf jeden fall die
außengrenzen sichern solange die
außengrenzen löchrig sind wie ein
schweizer käse dann wird es nicht
gelingen freizügigkeit innerhalb europas
aufrecht zu erhalten was wir wollen es
wird aber auch nicht gelingen sicherheit
zu gewährleisten beides ist vital für
diese europäische union da ruht das
vertrauen darauf der menschen die in
europa vor allem die in utah sozusagen
und vertrauen haben und deswegen muss
brüssel handeln es möglichst schnell mit
den sanktionen
ja das asylsystem funktioniert nicht
innerhalb der europäischen union wir
brauchen ein sicheres gemeinsames system
auch mit sozusagen
in den dublin verfahren und der
rückstellung aber auch die länder die
außengrenzen haben müssen ihre
außengrenzen schützen für die
europäischen union das machen die polen
und deswegen verdienen sie nicht nur
dank sondern unsere volle unterstützung
dabei wie wollen sie bei den grünen
künftig auch an der regierung her imrich
lukaschenko putin die stirn bieten in
dieser so schwierigen auseinandersetzung
vor zwei wochen war hier im bild live
studio am sonntag erik marquardt ihr
flüchtlings experte der hat gesagt da
sitzen nur noch ein paar hundert in
minsk das reißt jetzt langsam ab fakt
ist da kommen immer mehr flugzeuge nach
das ist halt organisierter menschen
handelt da kommt immer mehr das war
schon mal falsch also wie wollen sie
künftig lukas schenk und putin hat die
stirn bieten als grüner also zum einen
muss man ja sehen wer gerade noch die
bundesregierung stellt das sind ja gar
nicht wie grün es gibt da eine
geschäftsführung der bundesregierung und
das hat paul ronzheimer finde ich
gestern sehr treffend getwittert als er
gesagt hat dass man sich schon die frage
stellen kann so was braucht man diese
bundesregierung noch überhaupt wenn es
haben wir auch genauso thematisiert sie
haben völlig recht und die lassen wir
auch nicht aus der verantwortung das ist
hier kein austeilen in eine richtung das
findet hier nicht statt darauf können
wir uns sofort einigen helmerich wir
sehen ganz klar wo die verantwortung
liegt aber wir gucken ein bisschen
sorgenvoll wenn wir auch sie gerade
gehört haben und erik marquardt gehört
haben in die zukunft der ampel also wie
wollen sie lukaschenko als grüner die
stirn bieten ja wir haben ja ganz klar
gesagt dass es verschärfte sanktionen
braucht gegen das belarussische regime
auch gegen die wirtschaftssektoren dass
es auch strafen geben muss gegen die
fluggesellschaften die dieses system mit
am leben halten und das ist der punkt
das muss jetzt passieren und dann muss
natürlich auch müssen auch weiter
gespräche geführt werden innerhalb der
europäischen union mit polen
belarus oder das trifft sich jetzt mit
der opposition
auf sky also da passieren dinge und da
kann man sich sicher sein dass die ampel
hier dann auch wenn sie in amt und würde
ein gutes verfahren und eine gute
politik umsetzen wird
vielen herzlichen dank ihnen beiden für
diese diskussionen wir bleiben an diesem
thema natürlich weiter dran danke ihnen
soweit